[Music]
episode six is pretty explosive
[Music]
how would you describe the second half
of the season oh gosh certainly for my
character that and catapults me into a
different experience creates a real
shift for a lot of the characters
dangerous it's on so here's I'll tell
you what I what I said after I read
their last script can we actually do
this okay it's something to watch
well it doesn't let up there's despair
there's Gilead and it's full force
there's hope there's resilience
there's rebellion I just it's thrilling
I have to say things get turned up in in
a real way you know in a way that's kind
of like irreversible I think the
resistance is real
awkward really resist in a way we
haven't seen before it gets more
explosive forever do you think we're
gonna end up in the beginning you just
never know you could never guess where
we're gonna be at the end quite honestly
in the state like it just falls apart is
all I'm saying it falls apart you think
that everything is going to be okay and
then everything goes to hell can I say
how yeah everything goes to hell so it's
it's great it really is kind of huge
it's messed up it's semester like I know
bits and pieces it's messed up we need
to find those among us who wish to do us
harm you can trust me
[Music]